this is uh quite a journey for everyone
especially for Harrison I saw it when I
was 15 when it came out it was 42 years
ago and now I'm here so it's surreal
honestly I learned so much such a an
enriching experience you know from crew
to cast it's just amazing I feel
like I felt Community dream right now
I didn't feel real it's a very moving
story about getting older and in a way
that's sort of what is happening to him
this is gonna surprise people and and
catch them in the throat I've seen all
the pieces live not glued together so
you can imagine how excited I am to
finally see it a year later we have
strong stories you do that add a little
John Williams to it and you gotta move